I think any man God made I mean not only
that I would God as well I'll tell ya
some booza party I never am at backwards
in my foresight ever since Connor he
declared like he's a god if all I want
we gonna win this fight no Irish teen no
Irish whiskey nobody can know no man can
win no I'll make you guys how you doing
so we got Conor McGregor and we got
Habib from Dagestan who they're gonna be
fighting yes and let's see if we can
derive some benefits and I want people
to after listening to us to really not
just stand behind a fighter because late
maybe he throws a good hook or maybe
he's got a good takedown but why don't
we get into some of the things that they
represent sure that's very important
it's very important what you bring to
the table okay I bring it to the table a
left hook this one brings to the table
some tremendous great takedowns but
what's behind that what does the person
stand for and let's see what the people
after we kind of dissect this let's see
who they're gonna feel like they or what
the person represents they'll fee be
more inclined to what do you thing about
that I think it's great yeah you want to
start with I think the easiest one to
start with is Conor McGregor and he's
you know he's got I say bigger following
in the States and in the West and he is
he's the money fighter right he just got
off the fight with Floyd Mayweather and
he's bought a lot of that traction over
with him to the UFC again he's got his
own brand of whiskey now being promoted
in the UFC and he's gonna be making the
most amount of money any UFC fighter
will so I think that's easy choice let's
start with that let's start with because
many people there they get that what we
were talking about that dopamine Mike's
right right they watch him with the lewd
behavior and really getting rowdy and
not thinking about okay what does this
represent so I want people who
had let's say a separation the fat many
people now skyrocketing staggering
statistics of broken homes sure due to
alcoholism rapes it's happening every
like sixty seventy seconds something
like that from driving we're not talking
about even what you just mentioned
basically they're saying who the World
Health Organization estimates that there
is one death every ten seconds due to
alcohol alcohol can you imagine it I
think what's more important is that okay
find the who mentioned the deaths but
what was the recent study that came out
what is the about zero benefit yeah
there's a there's a study if you're a
drinker we hate to be the ones to break
some sobering news to you but a major
new study says no amount of alcohol is
good for your overall health
not even that cheeky glass of red wine
you might be holding as we speak on
Friday evening a survey in The Lancet
medical journal says the overall risk of
liquor outweighs any known benefits
it says alcohol accounted for nearly one
in 10 deaths in people between the ages
of 15 and 49 that data was recorded in
2016 across all age groups alcohol was
associated with 2.8 million deaths that
year before before I mentioned that ok
so what we're trying to do here is for
someone who's had because all of these
things are in the backbone because you
might not have committed the direct
crime but if you're somehow you're
complicit in it you're helping to
facilitate something that's alcohol
obviously and this is this is one of the
things that the major thing that you get
when now because Connors promoting
promoting his brand of alcohol be got
beyond the fight so now I mentioned rape
I've mentioned what else breakups of
family death deaths all of these things
think of the worst things and someone in
one way or another has been affected
their family has somehow been touched by
alcohol my name is Jacqueline so would
either
this is a picture of me before I was hit
by a drunk driver before the car caught
fire before two of my friends died
before I needed more than 40 operations
this is me when my life was just like
anyone else in college this is me after
being hit by a drunk driver I grew up
with a friend and I obviously I won't
mention his name but we were in middle
school in grade school and his father
was an alcoholic
and I was there on some occasions when
the family would have problems and
fights and it definitely had a huge
detrimental effect on the family but
what was unfortunate is that the son
wound up being an alcoholic as well
right mm-hmm so just think about it from
that perspective copying his father
copying his father so the father was
responsible for breaking or damaging the
family structure but now indirectly or
directly the son is following in the
footsteps and I know we're going to talk
about this later but this is why it's
even important to talk about social
media like you mentioned the dopamine
release media in general and what what
values are we putting forth through
these avenues and means and the reality
is what you got you know our phone is
right here right all of us got our
phones all of us have instant access all
of us are living on social media and
living on the Internet what is it that
we are exposed to at a high rate and we
have to draw a parable why is it that
Conor McGregor's alcohol brand is a
co-sponsor it's because it brings in
money well why does it bring in money
because alcohol sales are important
right and they're it's not like they're
putting the quotes of very noble and
pious men on the ring or they're putting
quotes of the founding fathers of the
country or they're putting quotes of you
know just scientists or whatever
whatever you have you they're putting
sponsors under and the sponsors are
those who can bring the most value or
give you the most money so what is it
that we are really pushing down people's
throat and I think that's where we
should focus this is very important that
you guys sit through this episode
because you don't see anyone you turn
into all the commentators and they're
talking about who has the advantage
technically and what's going to happen
nobody's talking about
the moral dilemma here the moral
responsibility this what we're talking
about I challenge you to sit through it
and really think because this is
something that now is having a great
impact on what we just talked about the
son the father the son imitating the
father this is happening rampant in our
society and when you look at Conor
McGregor and now you're just blindly
following him and now you're with his
brand and you're from there you know
imitating not only his speech his
patterns and just what's the end result
you have to look at the extreme what's
you keep going what's what's he bringing
to the table that you're gonna leave
with at the end that's what your warrant
are looking beyond the feel-good or the
entertainment you know the thing is look
this is a culture and a time of instant
gratification right so the the part
about social media is this you jump on
facebook you jump on Instagram you jump
on the internet on YouTube because
you're looking for that instant pleasure
so now it's so easy to fix that crate or
to get that fix you have a craving you
just jump on the internet you want to be
entertained you just jump on the
internet you want to be aroused you jump
on the internet whatever you want you
can find it on the internet right now
what's the problem with that the problem
is it's hard to turn that off and what
is the sign showing what is the science
show the sign science is showing that
it's rewiring the brains right so the
you know one example that I that I
studied when I was in this group called
Academy em it's a millennial mentorship
group is that Millennials are looking
for gratification right away right so
once they take a nice selfie or they
have a unique post they put it out there
and if people respond as they want they
get their release of dopamine right and
if people don't respond the way they
want is the exact opposite depression
sadness you don't feel like you're
validated so now we have someone who is
a millennial Connor McGregor is a
millennial so he displays many
millennial tendencies so how has he made
his bread and butter
sure he's a fighter but there's plenty
of great fighters out there right why is
he
paid towards the highest how did he get
that fight with Floyd Mayweather was he
literally the best UFC fighter to fight
Floyd probably not right he's a good
striker but he did a great job at
self-promotion talking about himself
digging himself up what is the problem
that we have with the youth and social
media right now and this is official
data and in a normal conversation like
this the data shows that a person will
refer to themselves or talk about their
own experience thirty to forty percent
of the time but when when they are on
the internet or they're on social media
they're talking about themselves eighty
to ninety percent of the time
eighty to ninety percent so now we've
gone from thirty to forty percent in a
in a conversation like this to eighty to
ninety percent and the internet so now
how do we connect these two things okay
I see as someone who's young I see Conor
McGregor he's made it right and in terms
of the dunya he's made it he's known
people loved him people respect him he's
a good fighter people want to get his
brand of clothing his brand of alcohol
the Mac life on youtube people want to
subscribe to it but how has he made it
he's made it up he's made it by talking
about himself so now if I'm a fan I said
okay I got to talk about myself but what
are some of the other things that I got
to do he's violent I gotta act violent
he's a bit outlandish maybe I have to
act outlandish so a bit I think that's
that's an understatement
so you have so let's go to that study
sure so the study you're talking about I
believe it was in The Lancet
it talks about that no amount of alcohol
is good for the human health you had
this common saying that a glass of wine
alcohol moderation this was something
that people were commonly known to say
and that this would motivate even the
person that was kind of like
health-conscious then he would read this
in men's magazine but all of this stuff
was funded by the alcohol industry right
so this new study is giving the facts
that no amount of alcohol not only that
now when we look at so this is the one
thing we're hitting first we covered a
few other points about the lewdness and
the disrespect and the behavior the but
this is so important because
I don't think there's many people that
haven't been touched by the direct or
somehow indirect consequence of
alcoholism or alcohol brings to the
table and we talked about that one in
one death every second I mean this is
this is by who the World Health
Organization talks about there's one
deaf akuto alcohol every ten seconds
there worldwide 3.3 million people die
each year this is more than the
combination of AIDS they say
tuberculosis and violence can you
imagine that it's not surprising this is
how many people are dying for many
people they they they are this is the
first time they're hearing this but this
is just like can you imagine every every
10 seconds let me give you some more
look over there close to over 40% there
of the traffic deaths from again now
this is the range of the kids that are
watching him let's say from 16 to 20
some of the young kids they're due minds
their bodies are developing and now he's
promoting the alcohol and almost 40
percent of deaths in this range is from
this peer group let me give you another
one it's alcohol is the they say the
third leading cause of deaths death and
now what does it have on the economy and
I'm just giving you some snippets but
when people go down this and they start
really looking into in 2010 they
estimated around 250 billion dollars in
America suffered the economy suffered to
misuse of alcohol look I think the the
summary for all this is what he is not a
role model right and we have to we have
to bring that into perspective at the
end of the day he can do whatever he
wants and everyone is judged based on
their actions right what what you what
you reap is what you sow
but the point is why is it that we are
turning to people like him as a role
model so number one something we have to
make clear to the youth is he is not a
role model and no twin no shape of the
manner right we cannot turn to someone
like this and say okay this is for
example if I were to do or you were to
do what Conor McGregor has done we
probably be in jail let's talk about
that next so we brought all
all to the table now compare the
contrast that we try to Habib let's
bring Habib into the X he was offered
hubby
Conor tried to offer Habib some alcohol
and then Habib said I don't drink never
drink and this is due to Islam and then
he called him backwards then he called
him backwards but then we just did
bunked there because you see I mean sit
backwards because you're trying to save
lives and all these are preventable
deaths right well you try you're also
trying to make money you're also trying
to live the high life and you're also
trying to get the most following on
social media and you're also trying to
get a stake in the UFC
it depends what are your goals what are
your values it reminds me of the last
and final messenger prophet Muhammad
peace and blessing be upon him he said
cursed is the one the worshipper of the
dollar of the dinar of the money so a
person like this I mean if you want to
get because the Conor McGregor he went
from claiming that he's a God next to
God and me and Jesus are killed I'm
killed with all the gods gods recognized
God's not a man alive that can be me but
Jesus ain't alive is he so I don't you
know maybe if you could come back from
the dead nah I don't know
I'd still go I was gonna get it
regardless
sooner or later it's coming with or
without you
and then the God came and bless you
Willie ya know about that coffee think
any man God made you know I mean and not
only that I what God as well we talked
about this we don't show so any person
who a is a Christian and Catholics are
predominantly in that area where Ireland
Catholic right they're both they're both
so you would think wow he's claiming to
be a god we did a show on on this and
it's interesting that then he kind of
backed off and now he started to become
a Christian seem like a devout Christian
well semi according to the press
conference according to the press
conference but again if you if our
Christian and you stand on some morals
or a Jew or anything you wouldn't really
want to be backing someone like this
it's not a man alive that can be me but
Jesus ain't alive is he so I don't you
know maybe if you could come back from
the dead nah I don't know
I'd still would make any man God made I
mean not only that I'll whoop God as
well you brought up a good point about
the press conference and I'll touch upon
it lightly so I'll be let me be very
honest I don't have an outright hate for
Conor McGregor I don't I don't either
III do think he's a superior athlete
mm-hmm and if you were just to tone it
down a little bit I think you know he
even be entertaining and whatnot one of
the things that I had a problem with
with and you gave the example in the
beginning was after that first press
conference nobody really criticized some
of the things that he did or said some
people brought it up lightly right Dana
White even said it was dark but I think
people should have gone a little bit
more deeper than that because if the
shoe was on the other foot and if this
was say a foreigner and an on say you
know a foreigner from an Eastern more
part of the world I think people would
have been more critical but one thing
that kind of rubbed me the wrong way was
you know as Muslims we're not supposed
to mock other people's religions this is
very clear right yes we're not supposed
to mock other people's conceptions of
God and other religions and I think you
know one way of putting that is that is
common sense you don't want to offend
and talk about things that people hold
near and dear Cubs coach Habib's coach I
think Xavier Mendes he actually was
interviewed and he said look I teach my
fighters don't talk about religion don't
talk about politics don't talk about
family Connor talked about religion he
talked about politics and he talked
about family now javi Xavier is not a
Muslim but a lot of these principles
they transcend religion right we a lot
of us we have the same values and
rightfully so but my issue was he talked
about religion he talked about his
father he talked about him you know
disrespectful way he talked about his
culture all these things in overtly
disrespectful way so my point is yes you
have to promote the fights I get it the
more you promote the fights the more
money you make but like you said are we
going to be slaves to the dollar right
but the bigger issue is when the youth
are watching when the younger generation
are watching these empty vessels these
sponges and they live on the Internet
your purse ate your parents are at work
all day you have your phone you have
your tablet you can access whatever you
want now
you might not even look for this but
because it's trending you'll see it and
you'll see this guy who was dressed nice
he's sharp he's got a nice car he's got
money he's got people following
he's got a crowd supporting him you know
it's alert even someone like myself I'll
be very honest for a while I was hooked
on watching a lot of Conor McGregor
videos it becomes very it is almost like
a drug we brought up we brought that up
in the beginning right you get hooked
you have to kind of live on social media
but if you don't pull yourself out and
realize what damage that can do to you I
mean for all that we know some of this
may be acting on his part right he may
be a very slow guy but he knows that I
have to promote my fight so let me act
in a way that people will buy in but
then the question is what are the
detrimental effects for this like what
you said this is not a something
personal against the individual himself
we did a program that we sent a message
to Conor and even talking about how he
can get the edge and then when you look
at the the message we sent is somehow to
kind of love and concern especially for
what you talk about the youth now this
is really important we talked about the
alcohol the disrespect to the elders I
mean imagine okay you let your kid go on
without any restrictions following
someone like him and now next to you
know as he does like come get a close-up
on my brand and says and f you that's a
bombs coming out and now the father is
trying to have relationship with his son
and you know how kids nowadays can get
really crazy and now you have this as a
role model he's like f you dad
he's doing the car he's got the Kandra
Conor McGregor's syndrome he's got the
hood effect and he's just like f-bombs
to his mother to his father and that's
what's gonna happen and then he's
throwing down with his whiskey brand
what else we got breaking the law that's
another thing when you come off okay we
all make mistakes none of us are perfect
but now you come into the United States
and I talked about this also I believe
with Allah Mohammed and I said what if
this was bilal mohammed the other UFC
guy brother very nice brother he ended
up doing that he said man he would have
been in jail he would have been you know
when he threw that yeah okay so you made
the mistake but now you come in and show
no respect to the law to the people that
you hurt and now you using that and
putting the promotional material the
promotional material with no no regret
now he said you know in the
again some of it if you if you if the
implications were not so serious you
could really just sit back and laugh at
it right but they're serious basically
when you refer to the window of the bus
he said and I you know I smashed that
window and then he crossed himself and
he said God
God rest his soul yeah but for me that's
like making a mockery of what happened
now free you know the legal aspect is
one part of it but for me again let's
take it back to society let's take it
back to the youth to the children that's
what you really keep straight this is
very important because you can maybe
decipher it we're at the young but the
young what you're saying they you and I
are older right yeah now I was listening
to a very good podcast earlier about
social media and the woman was talking
about she's been on technology since
birth but she remembers a time where
there was a disconnect so because she
had that experience without being with
tech she knows how to use it so now
these kids who grow up with technology
and social media this is what they see
and this is what gets the hits and the
radians and it becomes viral now what's
the issue with this okay
how did now his friend his friend artem
which is important to mention his friend
Artem called Habib a certain word right
which was disrespectful and then Habib
kind of found him in a corridor and
slapped him up a little bit now I'm not
vouching for either side right we're not
gonna say one was right and one was
wrong but look there was a reaction
there was an initial action and then a
reaction but what did Conor do is to
undercut as soon as he found out about
it he got his boys on a private jet they
flew over here and they looked for
revenge right the question is if you're
if you were teaching someone from the
society how to deal with their problems
like I gave you the example earlier say
a friend of yours say me you know I call
us Eddie I called this guy the B word
and then he found he saw me and he
slapped me up the priority that you
should emphasize is advising me not
backing me up and saying okay let's get
that guy because who was the one that
made the fault it was me I shouldn't
have cursed at the guy right so what is
it that we're teaching the young
generation is it that okay something
like this happens you got to get your
boys and go handle business if you go
handle business you know what's gonna
happen right you know why end up in jail
yeah so this is all of the things we we
talked about that
this is what connor brings to the table
he brings can we say a lot of arrogance
sure lewd behavior or irresponsible
behavior reckless behavior again it's
not an attack on him personally as a
pert but this is the behavior that now
we're asking you to think about as a
Christian a Jew as even an atheist that
has some good manners some morals and
wants the best for his children his
family in society because it's a
trickle-down effect if everyone starts
mimicking people like this and they stop
mimicking Jesus Moses Abraham problem
Hamid peace and blessings be upon him
these men never did those things these
are our examples so now let's get into
hobby because this is what Conner brings
to the table all of the some of the most
foul and dirty and unethical immoral
things to the table now he's great
fighter but this is also the baggage he
brings sure but let's big habib he's not
perfect
he's now someone who stated that thinks
that when i say like nobody in religion
was like nobody's perfect but religion
like Islam is perfect but the way of
life that he follows is perfect Islam so
what does he bring to the table let's
talk about that one of the things is
that if your kids follow him they won't
drink he's following Prophet Mohammed
his example so he doesn't he he
shouldn't be I don't see him cursing
much at all but if he does his entourage
or anything this is something that that
we asked the Muslims we asked people who
are watching this is one of the benefits
of doing this show because some people
they you have you have to get involved
with what's going on in the culture
because you can't get a lot of people's
attention in any other way so we want to
derive the good from this and this is
one of the points it's very important
that no believer who believes in the
creator who follows this way of life who
praises the crater with his tongue
should be uttered we all make mistakes
there's those times you slip up you make
mistakes okay it's but it shouldn't be a
part of your vocabulary that is
naturally you're throwing out F bombs
look let's so there's that religious
principle right about lewd behavior
about obscenities about using foul
language right we have it in the Quran
and in the hadith that we're not
supposed to use this now let's just make
it very simple whether someone is
Christian Jewish Muslim Hindu Sikh
atheist it doesn't matter
most people probably have a consensus
that foul language and obscenities are
something that bother most people right
so if I go to an atheist or a Jew or a
Christian and I swear at them I drop an
f-bomb and I curse their parents even
though they're not Muslim they're
probably gonna have an issue with that
so a lot of these things are very
commonsensical right we don't do these
things because they offend people like
one thing that we brought up earlier we
were not supposed to mock other people's
religions but you had him kind of
indirectly mocking how Bebe's religion
right so as it seemed but a lot of these
principles are there because they make
sense and Islam for me again it's about
tranquility living in peace we're trying
to live peaceful eyes we're not trying
to upset the balance you see Habib again
not perfect he has his problems right
but he brings a lot of good to the table
and that cannot be denied even even to
the extent that even guys like Joe Rogan
who you know I think is an agnostic or
an atheist and a lot of these other guys
comment on his level of devoutness and
the fact that he seems even keel
he seems non-emotional he's as cold as
ice in a good way right he's not very
reactionary so yeah and he's these are
these are good program because you get
some of these fighters who tune in and
again a we're all works in progress so
maybe they didn't get this information
and maybe someone will stop with the
also as a Muslim with that lewd behavior
because no Muslim should be cursing no
no Muslim should be something
threatening and acting in the gangster
this is this whole idea you hear these
you know this gangster gangster equals
you could say you know what Jah Hill
means Jah Hill someone who's ignorant
have deen when you have Deen you're not
a gangster you're trying to it was the
problem Hamid peace and Buzzard upon him
a gangster know so you're here imitating
the best of mankind who was sent as a
mercy to mankind he was not a gangster
some of his Sahaba were gangsters then
they accepted Islam and they became the
best of mankind so we're trying to get
away from the gangster life doesn't mean
now you're a coward you don't stand up
for certain morals principles and you
defend yourself and you you know you're
a man's man that's different but going
around and spreading this because we
know the connotations now when you say
gangster what again what are the young
minds think look like like we mentioned
earlier right this this word gangster
and what is the
we've made the word cool right and it's
been cool for maybe God knows how long
at least since the 90s right but the
word gangster you hear it in movies you
hear in music you hear it in TV
man that guy's a gangster man did you
see how he reacted he's a gangster we've
connected that with someone being you
know straight to the point
authentic taking care of business but
you can do those things without being a
gangster right without being in your
face without cursing people without
disrespecting people so again the point
is who connects who or who controls the
meaning of these words what do they
really mean what influence do these
words have on the youth and when our
youth do watch these things and they
hear these words and again what do we
want them imitating so if you use an
example of school you're gonna want your
son or your daughter to imitate the a
student right you're not gonna want them
to imitate the D or the F or even the C
student that's clear to most people yeah
you see someone with good study habits
or good work habits someone he's
punctual he gets to work on time she
gets to work on time they leave on time
they put in there all you're gonna say
no be like that person don't be like the
person who takes two-hour lunches but
then when it comes to this it's like
people have a dilemma they don't know
you know should I be like the guy who's
been in jail and who's promoting you
know vices and promoting getting 4050
guys on a plane coming over attacking
someone or should I be like someone
who's a little bit more even q and again
we're not we don't believe in hero
worship right so the point is not to
Kobe B or Habib is the role model and
we're following Habib only and Connor's
the role model and we're following no no
it's what are the principles what are
the values
whoever prescribes to the principles and
values we're cool with right so if
Connor prescribes to the principles and
values huh we're cool with it and and I
think though the only reason what what
caught my my heart is when I saw someone
making such done and this connected me
and I'm sure all those people who came
to visit there's a clip and you'll see
Habib and we we are behind him when he
is calling people to the creator he says
be humble and this is what the Dean this
is for all of human be humble if all
along
along with you nobody can stop you man
no Irish team no Irish whiskey nobody
can say this is impossible virtually
number one important most important for
us stay connect with God because without
this like money family nothing give you
like like like you have connect with God
you know even doesn't matter what
happened with you what's like you always
have to pray you always have to stay
humble and stay focused and stay connect
with God this is very important for us I
mean this is you UFC champ I'll or not
doesn't matter as opposed to now Connor
be arrogant would you want your child to
be humble humble that's what he provides
at the table be humble we will all of
our children to be in front of you be
humble to their parents to be to be to
be good kids
arrogant kids listen this look at it
this way yeah are they're humble people
are there people who don't get into
trouble in the UFC that make money there
are ok so there's a there's a room for
that so we got to make that cool we got
to make that the new cool or humble
right not the more arrogant because what
the arrogant behavior is destructive
behavior and it trickles down to all of
the negative things that impact the
individual his family and society it's a
road to destruction Habib made a
statement and we love him for that he
said stay humble he's talking to the
youth and they had these shirts God is
the greatest
and don't go to the bathroom with those
shirts yeah now so he says be humble and
stay connected to God I mean how can you
go wrong doing that number one important
most important clause stay connected
with the Garden State beautiful advice
and then he's humbling himself after the
fights he doesn't do like many of the
pompous right people they end up banging
each other chatter just pompous like me
that's the arrogant behavior he points
away and this again this is what touches
us this is why many Muslims
for that that somewhat hero but our
hero's problem ha myself some but it's
nice to have where your kids somehow you
can connect them back to the Dean
somehow because with all of the evil
influences you got some someone's out
there so that's that's being a good
example in today's age where it's very
very difficult to find good examples
good role models they're looking for
good mentors we're looking for good
mentors so he's saying stay connected to
your Creator stay connected to prayer
look at that youth he's saying things
that are hundred percent correct in this
aspect and when he humbles himself and
he doesn't say look it's me it's me he
points up he did what Jesus did he did
what all the messengers of God did
Prophet Mohammed being the last funny
message they pointed up they said that
all that love adoration and the master
that you should serve is not the dollar
or yourself or your ego but the one who
created you and that's what you get
not a commonality when now what habib is
bringing to the table and that's all
link back to islam i was gonna say that
when you said about serving the master
not even your friends because that's
important right why did Connor do what
he did to help his friend what was that
really help I mean we have to we have to
we have to like analyze this to a deep
point because what happened initially
when that incident happened Connor went
to jail and Dana white issue that Artem
was out of the UFC so how is that
helping Artem Artem was an aspiring UFC
fighter right so again I know I'm micro
analyzing this point but when we who do
we really serve do we serve our own ego
do we serve our desires we have to look
for the right role models and the right
mentors and again the point is social
media it has its benefits it also has
its negative connections and the the
release of dopamine we have to be very
wary of these instant feelings of
gratification these feelings of goodness
and one important thing that I was going
to bring up is that you know with the
wiring of the mind and with the the
release of the dopamine we have to be
very wary of technology in general so
one thing that I like about Habib is the
fact that he always praises not only the
creator but is thankful to
the people he is thankful to his family
we got to connect with our families
again we got to connect with our
intimate and close friends we got to
re-establish those good connections that
that are emphasized even in our religion
that we should keep but even that our
very common sense right people who are
good friends and good family members and
you put them as your support circle
around you it only leads that you are
who is around you right yeah so if you
have a good circle of friends there's a
good likelihood if you're if you're
surrounded by entrepreneurs
valedictorians of universities and high
schools this is a good chance you're
gonna be either an entrepreneur or
valedictorian or somewhere closer to
them yes but if you're surrounding
yourself with gangsters and thugs and
dare I say losers what are you gonna be
you're gonna be a loser and it's easier
to be a loser at the end of the day you
can have all this money and all the fame
and all the glitz and the glamor but at
the end when you leave this life
that's what's gonna count when you're in
the grave and we're all gonna be there
and now you transfer from this life
because that's what much of the talk is
about the commentator it's all about you
know the person's last lettis ISM and
you know we're talking beyond that right
and we talk about the heart the soul the
mind these are making a complete
holistic human being and Conor McGregor
what we give him his vice and this is
important what you said this is also
what you get with Habib he honors his
parents his mother and father I mean
just think about that when you as a
parent when you have your children
disrespect you that's like the worst
thing that you breastfed this child this
child you put him through school you
gave him everything and that child turns
around and gives you an f-bomb can you
imagine what that does to a parent yeah
I'm sure it breaks her heart gives
thanks to his homey friends his gangster
friend and forgets to thank you as his
mother or his father and this is what we
have the teachings of the Prophet
Muhammad who said that paradise lies
under your mother's feet look at that
you know the disrespect of the parents
will get you a ticket to the Hellfire so
Habib is living up to that that's
another great example and we would give
Conners
advice to go ahead and marry this young
lady I mean because if we follow again
that example again where promiscuity and
this lewdness in in sexuality this is
the decay of society you know Salahuddin
oub
he had a famous quote he said if you
want to destroy a society make this
promiscuity this sexual immorality
ramped it and that's and that's another
contribution to just a break of humanity
if you really want to save society look
think of it as smaller circles and then
grow into bigger circles people often
focus on the outer part of the circle
which is doing very high-level things
but if you don't got the inner part of
the circle which is maintaining the
order in the house right so now I have a
household I have to make sure I'm
treating my spouse my children correctly
and I'm acting just I have to make sure
I'm treating my parents justly to make
sure I'm treating my extended family
members justly I have to make sure I'm
treating my neighbors justly I have to
make sure I'm treating my you know
community members justly it's it's in
steps it's in stages now what happens if
we do those things society is at peace
is that harmony No Child Left Behind
people are going to school people are
getting educated people are being taken
care of but we have these overarching
goals and these high ambitions but the
houses are broken right mm-hmm you got
to start off at stage one at step one
before you get to the further steps yes
and again I think you know the last
point for me is validation how do you
get your validation if you're getting
your validation like we see he's getting
which is promoting alcohol swearing
picking fights with people right alleged
violence that means if I'm if I'm a
millennial if I'm someone who's younger
who was tied to the social media tied to
this technology that means I'm gonna
look for validation the same way because
if it works for him
it should work for me right but people
are not making that connection you try
to do that stuff either you're gonna get
knocked out are you gonna go to jail
yeah or you know so people got to wake
up people got to realize that they're
looking for validation in the wrong
places yes look for validation here
there's a lot that can be talked about
you know just that whole industry with
the gambling with the alcohol with the
naked ring girls all this stuff this is
something antithesis to Islam we
obviously we don't support these kind of
things let's just get this clear this is
we're talking about because it's part of
the norm in the culture I mean this is
now almost probably everybody is kind of
talking about it you know not the adults
the kids the young ones so we want to
reach out with a positive message to the
minute what do you call them
Millennials that's the new term for the
age group the age group yeah
and now for for the people like Habib
who are out there they're already doing
this we're not getting in this is halal
Haram we know what Islam stance on it
but if you're already and I like this I
and I hope that we have some of the same
friends me and Habib and weave because
people have been asking me and I'm
getting I want them to start because
they've been asking when's Habib coming
on the show right so now we're in the
talks I had what we've interpreted as a
promise from his manager to have him on
the program but this is something that
that now we've talked about since you're
in the spotlight initial of the message
got to him that now you're doing like
what Muhammad Ali did he used this
platform to share to share the purpose
with people to share the good moral
message with the people of this Deen and
because Allah don't care the crater
don't care about your belts yeah he
don't care about this fight legacy a
person could be 50 you know Allah don't
care God don't care about that but what
have you done with the time allocated to
you in this dunya in this world what
have you done with your time to help
make this world a better place exactly
what have you done this is the thing
that we have to reflect because that's
not going to transfer into the currency
into the next slide of the good deeds
that you have to show it's not but if
you use this platform now Habib and
others like that you have it and the
spotlight comes to you and you say I'd
like to take a timeout and think the
creator of the heavens and earth who
gave me this ability I couldn't throw a
punch or a right hand or a hook without
this blessing and he's given me this
help and I'm gonna thank him first and
foremost before the people go down with
a list of people I like to thank my
promoter and my mother's brother they
forget about the arc the spider the one
who gave you all the blessings don't
forget about that and we love Habib
because he does that continue to do that
and this is very very important because
the problem hummus Osama had talked
about that it's it's there paraphrasing
the hadith how dangerous it is when the
prepar overpraised
yes it kills a person so keeping it
humble keeping it like he's been keeping
it keep it humble and deflect that
attention from you to the Creator to
this Deen and keep moving forward
helping the youth and not succumbing to
many of the temptations that are out
there that can destroy the heart to
weaken the heart and kill the human
being spiritually I I want to I think
you know it's just I can't say it better
but not just inviting kabhi inviting
Conner that's right and you know again
it's up to him you know I like guys for
me personally people follow what they
want to follow right but at least at
least while you're here spread goodness
spread goodness brother benefit people
you know no alcohol open up schools make
it easier for people to get educated
open up training seminars opening up
open up workshops spread goodness open
up an entrepreneur entrepreneur teach
people how to become entrepreneurs in a
more ethical way right so for both of
them you know hopefully after the fight
they can bury the hatchet
there's no animosity that lingers over
and I'm sure that's gonna have to also
start with some apologies because
certain things have been said but I
truly for me I want good for both of
them yeah Conners shown me some good
signs he is loyal to his people he is
loyal to his countrymen but he's got to
take it to a more neutral zone music
where the loyalty doesn't come at the
expense of disregarding another group
mm-hmm and that's it and this is what
you have in history you've seen people
who are like that they were loyal maybe
to their tribe their national
nationality to all of these worldly
things but when you are devoted to your
Creator and now you have like Conner you
have because he doesn't have that moral
compass now you have the moral compass
you sincerely reach out to the creator
of the heavens and say guide me why am I
here what's my purpose am I going to
just live died and has become dust no
there's another reality that opens up
just like the child comes out of the
womb it's a whole new reality that opens
up we are gonna die and it's a whole new
reality you can ignore it but it's not
gonna make it go away
a whole new reality is gonna come up
when you have the blueprint Islam gives
the blueprint it gives us everything we
need so if Conner gets that I'm sure he
could become the best
the best your predictions for the fight
you know it's tough man Connor is a
superior striker he's become a better
striker since he was prepping to fight
Mayweather obviously we know khabib is a
great grappler the crazy thing is I like
both of them as fighters
I like their styles and their antithesis
their opposites
if khabib is sloppy like he was in the
last fight and I'm sorry it could be
business in him as he mentioned himself
he was watching a lot of Muhammad Ali
fights and he was relaxed he was very
comfortable but if he if he charges and
you know his his his hands are down and
his chin is exposed Conor might put him
to sleep but if he's a little bit
patient if he's a little bit patient and
Connor's a little bit overactive like he
said he's going to be Connor said from
the time the bell rings he's gonna go
after him
I think Kobe was gonna grab him and get
him on the ground it's gonna be a long
night yeah so I I don't it's not a clear
answer but I don't know here's what I
think and again we're not profits we're
not messengers you know when Jesus in
mark 13:32 when he was asked of that day
or hour I'm just making this conscious
you can see what we're talking about he
was asked when's the day of judgment he
said no one knows nor any man but the
crater alone so we don't know the future
we can have some foresight in my
foresight ever since Connor he declared
like he's a goddess my god any man God
made I mean and not only that I will God
as well I was thinking I said Subhan
Allah if Allah the Creator raises up a
beep I can see him bringing someone
who's become so arrogant ain't any man
God made I mean not only that I'll whoop
God as well then he's gonna slap him
down again we don't know the future but
I'm just saying you know this is
something that the thoughts that go
through our mind
I see potentially the loss want Allah
using Habib to smack someone who's come
up so high so far down and inshallah
that could be such a blessing if Connor
uses it and then look back at the one
who Allah used Habib to smack him so far
down from his arrogance and to inshallah
humble him because when a person is
connected to their crater right the fear
that Allah will put into their
their opponents the strength that you
come when Muhammad Ali was asked when he
was when I spoke with Mossad beccaj and
he had drifted away from the Deen and
then he started to think and then he
compared it to Muhammad Ali I had place
on Masada was like man I relate to that
where Muhammad Ali was like oh it's
because of my abilities because it is
but then he started praying five times a
day he started to connect 100% with
Allah with the Creator and then he was
like when Allah is with you there is
nothing no old man can do to you pray
and at 5:00 in the morning
this goes on if when I'm right now I
didn't do that for the first phrase to
fight novice at first norton fight
really no sir
our head got big and I start thinking it
was my training camp at my boxing
ability that kept me where I was that
and God punished me and he gave me a
good whooping he broke my jaw in the
sacrum fight and he got me whooped and
knocked down in the Frazier fight and I
realized I wasn't that great after all
so I had to get not only together
physically but spiritually for this
fight I've prayed every day for five
days five times a day for the past of
four months and everything is perfect
and if I lost with me it ain't no way no
man can win no way so when you have the
Creator when you have that resilience
when you have that in you and if Allah
uses now that he's already in here and
he uses him to humble this person maybe
again we don't know and then maybe and
that's the the the dua we make that
through this inshaallah Conner can get
guided and then he sees like wow this
what's this guy about you know what I
mean he looks back and again it connects
back to Dean to Islam Islam he's perfect
I want to say like this then he starts
to look at the Quran and from there all
the goodness happens inshallah you know
this is what what is on my mind and what
has been what I've been thinking form it
in summer you were hoping hoping for
good for both that good comes from yeah
yeah from from both inshallah both of
them yeah so inshallah people can
benefit from this little short episode
that we did talking about this and at
the end summing it up is what they bring
to the table leave with that what they
bring and what days
stand for at the end what they're
bringing we've made a list of things and
now it's on you to contemplate and
reflect and from there tune in every
week to the Dean Shaw and if you want
like I've been saying many people
they've been asking when is Habib what
do you recommend making it tell them to
make it go viral right now
go ahead it's a hash tag I don't know
what is his handle is but find out
Habib's handle hash tag it and tell him
to come on the Dean show yeah you guys
been asking me for a long time to see
what's up was holding up some some
politics over here but we can get
because I keep saying you've been on
every other show every other dunya show
why not come on the Dean show Dean what
does Dean show is a way of life it's the
Dean it's Islam come on one of the only
Islamic TV talk shows in America what's
your excuse not to come on I mean what
do you think that's a fair proposition
fair huh and I think those Muslims the
ones who came who were rooting him on
who came though did you see that had all
the yeah you can see they're all they be
are excited and and and and and and the
rest of the audience inshallah we'll
have him on soon inshallah God willing
and keep saying in sha allah keep
connecting it back to allah and we hope
to see you back here on the dean show
every week new show God willing until
then peace be with you
Islamic subscribe to the DCO follow us
on our official Facebook and Twitter
pages in the links below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below
[Music]